hablemos un poco de las unidades usuales
de peso en eeuu la unidad de peso más
típicamente usada es la libra
especialmente para objetos que se
encuentran en la escala humana para
darnos una idea de lo que es una libra
la mayoría de las pelotas que se usa en
los deportes pesa aproximadamente una
libra por ejemplo un balón de fútbol voy
a hacer voy a dibujar un balón de fútbol
aquí lo tenemos vamos a ponerle aquí sus
costuras con los hexágonos que
usualmente tiene esto sería un balón de
fútbol el cual pesa aproximadamente una
libra la abreviatura que se usa para
libra es el punto así es que este balón
pesa aproximadamente una libra un balón
de fútbol americano dibujemos lo aquí
con su peculiar forma de ovoide también
tiene sus costuras como bien sabemos un
balón de fútbol americano también pesa
aproximadamente una libra así tienes una
idea de lo que representa una libra si
vamos a una escala más pequeña de la
libra
estaríamos usando la ons
estaríamos usando la onza y cuando
piensas en la relación que hay entre
libra y onza en términos de peso
entonces se sabe que una libra una libra
equivale es igual a 16 onzas o también
que una onza una onza es igual a 1 sobre
16 de libra una 11 equivale a un
dieciseisavo de una libra y si quieres
imaginar qué es lo que pesa una onza una
pequeña caja de cerillos una pequeña
caja de cerillos pesa aproximadamente
una onza pesa próximamente una onza
también una batería pequeña una batería
doble a una batería doble a también pesa
aproximadamente una 11 es decir 16 cajas
de cerillos equivalen al peso de un
balón de fútbol o 16 baterías dobles
equivalen al peso de un balón de fútbol
americano ahora para medir pesos en una
escala mayor a la libra usaremos la
tonelada
a toneladas la cual podemos abreviar
como ton y una tonelada una tonelada es
igual a 2000 libras una tonelada es
igual a dos mil libras tenemos que
precisar que nos estamos refiriendo a la
que se conoce como tonelada corta pues
existe la tonelada en el sistema
internacional la tonelada métrica sin
embargo dado que estamos hablando de las
unidades usuales en eeuu entonces nos
estamos refiriendo a esta tonelada la
tonelada corta equivalente a dos mil
libras y para tener una idea de lo que
son estos grandes pesos estos pesos de
2000 libras o más que es cuando
usaríamos la unidad de toneladas para
expresar dichos pesos un carro es un
buen ejemplo en promedio un carro de
esos tipos se dan más o menos de esos
que se conocen como compactos va a pesar
aproximadamente 2 toneladas es decir
tiene un peso aproximado de 4 mil libras
si hablamos de camionetas de pasajeros o
picops van a tener un peso mayor de 2
toneladas y si hablamos de los autos
conocidos como subcompactos
más pequeños que hay van a pesar menos
de 2 toneladas así es que hablando de un
auto un auto un carro va a tener un peso
aproximado de 2 toneladas espero que
esto te haya dado una idea de las
distintas unidades usuales en los eeuu
para las diferentes escalas de peso